so many restaurants out there where they
have signs we close early short of Labor
please be patient we don't want to do
that a lot has changed since covid
namely the workforce or lack thereof
making it a challenge for crazy Pita
owner Mary zalul to find people to fill
positions a lot of our students that
work with us like they work summer and
then they leave and for school or they
have activities or vacations his
solution technology pulling from a
Workforce more than 8 000 miles away
neither no robots but they are taking
customers by surprise think it's cool
something to get used to something I
definitely get used to but I mean time
for a change right first I thought it
was an Alexa and then I saw it actually
video chat my name is
19 year old husband and Ahmad greeting
people virtually on this tablet as they
walk in the door whenever I turn on my
camera and there are people coming in
you know daily life going in and they
come into a restaurant and they see me
they see a guy you know on a tablet and
they're like stunned they're like wow
where are you the most frequently Asked
question like where are you are you here
are you back at the kitchen hosnin is in
Pakistan getting his education during
the daytime and making ends meet by
putting in a 40-hour work week as a
virtual cashier overnight employed by a
company called Percy and do you get
break times as well
uh yes we do trained for three weeks
before starting crazy Peta is the fourth
restaurant chain for hasnin from afar
he's able to perfect the customization
for each order which then frees up the
other staff at crazy Peta to focus on
service we haven't lost anybody or a
place anybody we're using our
employees in towards other tests that
are directly connected with the customer
Medi says it's also more efficient no
one's standing around waiting on someone
to walk in the door since we started
using Percy
our rating and our stars have
skyrocketed we're getting a number of
five stars reviews on a constant basin
embracing technology for his restaurant
in fact the technology is quite common
in Europe and Canada but it's just now
getting started here in the U.S